des herbes hautes des fleurs qui
poussent où bon leur semble malgré les
apparences ce cimetière n'est pas à
l'abandon
en choisissant le zéro phyto l'asile du
mesnil-saint-denis fait partie des
trolls communes du parc naturel de
chevreuse à laisser la nature reprendre
ses droits
elle nous sommes passés en zéro phyto
complet à partir de 2014
la problématique que l'on a identifié et
est la problématique du cimetière qui
était voilà qui était envahi par les
mauvaises herbes
donc on a travaillé avec le pnr sur une
étude qui avait été proposé à toutes les
communes volontaires pour étudier le
mode de gestion des cimetières dans le
cadre du zéro phyto et pour lequel donc
le résultat de l'étude donné une
préconisation d'un énervement
donc on a eu un plan spécifique
d'enherbement être fleurissement sur sur
le cimetière
le parc de cheuvreux a mis en place une
matinée de rencontres entre élus et
techniciens de la ville un partage
d'astuces et de méthodes pour réduire
l'usagé des phytosanitaires dans les
cimetières
il faut prévoir des solutions
alternatives préventives comme limiter
l'entretien des espaces privilégiés
l'eau de pluie ou encore planter de
nouvelles espèces florales
les premiers résultats sur l'eau et les
milieux naturels sont visibles les
risques pour l'homme et la biodiversité
sont ainsi fortement réduit ces
rencontres ont pour but d'informer et de
sensibiliser aux bonnes pratiques à
adopter dans plusieurs communes du parc
un objectif à répandre dans d'autres
villes